bonjour à chacun et à chacune d'entre
vous donc en présentiel dans cette scène
ou à distance pour certains de nos
sénateurs et sénatrices mais aussi notre
invité de cet après midi donc chers
collègues nous commençons donc notre
programme de ce mardi par l'audition en
visio conférence de monsieur fils
philippe brillault pardon maire de
grigny et vous êtes signataire de
l'appel du 14 novembre 2020 émis par un
grand nombre de mersch pour qu'il vous
étiez son vin concernés par la politique
de la ville monsieur rioux je vous
remercie d'avoir accepté l'invitation de
notre mission de la formation robinet
est de rendre compte des phénomènes de
précarisation et de paupérisation qui
concerne pas les français
et notre objectif est de formuler des
propositions avec vos collègues
signataires de l'appel du 14 novembre
vous avez souhaité alerter le président
de la république sur l'évolution des
quartiers prioritaires de dakar et en
employant des expressions très fortes
comme notamment la non assistance à
territoires en danger c'est l'expression
vous avez utilisé je vous propose de
débuter cette audition par un propos
liminaire d'une quinzaine de minutes
vous pourriez notamment nous livrer vos
constats de terrain sur les sujets en
lien avec l'objet de nos travaux vous
pourriez également nous préciser comment
la situation a évolué dans votre ville
et chez vos collègues signataire depuis
l'appel du 14 novembre
la crise économique et sanitaire s'était
aggravé vous pourrez s'éclairicie sur
ces évolutions nous ouvrirons ensuite
une phase d'échangé en commençant par
les questions de notre rapporteur me
frédérique puissat et nous continuerons
avec les questions des sénateurs et
sénatrices membres de notre mission
d'information donc certains présentiel
et d'autres en distance yale comme vous
monsieur rio
je vous rappelle que cette audition fera
l'objet d'une captation vidéo qui sera
retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du sénat et sera consultable en
vidéo
est ce que vous entendez très bien
évidemment ça bien dont je vais vous
passez la parole monsieur rio pour une
présentation liminaire d'une quinzaine
de minutes et ensuite manaa rapporteur
et les autres sénateurs et sénatrices
c'est à vous merci de votre
sollicitation d'avoir accepté également
la vision un peu à l'isolément aux
cibles aucun contact donc c'est mieux
c'est mieux ainsi est un impératif
un peu avant 17 heures donc je vais être
le synthétique pour faire les échanges
oui nous sommes un noyau de demers qui
avons alerté le président de la
république dans ce courrier du 14
novembre avec vous l'avez dit des termes
forts de non assistance à territoires en
danger de décrochage républicain ou voir
même de virus république
ce mouvement fait suite à des annonces
successives de plans de relance qui
était de plus en plus terribles
territorialisées et là où certainement
nous constations un double phénomène
celui des premiers impacts massif des
conséquences économiques et sociales de
la crise qu'ovide conjuguée à une
surmortalité qu'ovide qui étaient
constatés en quartiers populaires pour
raison de logements non adaptés ou plus
petit voire cumulé pardon plus
exactement à des conditions de transport
d'un certain nombre de populations
qu'ils continuaient à travailler y
compris durant le premier confinement
sont les principales raisons liées
notamment à l'accès aux soins pour que
ce sont les trois critères qui sont
aujourd'hui bien identifiés par
différents rapports
y compris les chercheurs qui ont fait
cette démonstration là nous avons
effectivement alertés pour que le train
de la relance puissent s'arrêter à la
gare quartiers populaires qui je vous le
rappelle les quartiers croupe pv sont
les quartiers qui font l'objet d'une
discrimination positive parce que
concentration de pauvreté ah les fameux
la fameuse nous alami avec les dézonage
iris de l'insee qui permettent
d'identifier la concentration de pauvres
de mémoire 60 % en deçà du revenu médian
français
nous avons constaté lors du premier
confinement que excusez moi l'expression
l'armée des précaires qui constitue la
force de travail de nos quartiers
populaires avait du lourd au lendemain
cessé de travailler
une autre peau proportions et pardon
avait cessé de travailler sans filet de
sécurité
je parle je pense bien évidemment au
chômage technique pour ceux qui étaient
en cdi pour les activités qui ont cessé
pour les autres les seconds corvée les
premiers de corvée travailleurs ils ont
continué à travailler je pense bien
évidemment dans les métiers sanitaire
mais également dans les métiers de la
logistique
donc on a eu une partie des précaires
qui ont continué à travailler et une
partie qui se sont complètement éteint
avec avec le premier confinement et la
reprise d'activité n'ayant pas eu lieu
il n'y a pas une reprise d'activité et
donc de salaires nous avons très
rapidement constaté des difficultés en
lien avec nos bailleurs sociaux les
bailleurs sociaux des territoires b
l'augmentation des impayés les bailleurs
sociaux ont directement mis en place
l'ensemble de leurs dispositifs certains
ayant innover ayant échelonné mettant à
disposition leurs conseillers et
conseillères sociales
deuxièmement nous avons vu moi plus
particulièrement dans les copropriétés
en difficulté une explosion des impayés
de charges
très concrètement sur le territoire de
grigny les charges de chauffage et d'eau
qui sont gestion publique
ben nous avons pu voir mois par mois et
entre mars 2020 et décembre 2002 ben
plus 100% d'impayés eau et chauffage
donc là on est dans les copropriétés
fragile et dégradé c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons demandé à de la
création d'un observatoire des impayés
de charges en copropriété auprès de
madame la ministre du logement
emmanuelle wargon qui a été acté le 12
janvier dernier lors d'un comité de
pilotage annuel sur le plan initiative
copropriété nous avons demandé à fond
solidarité spéciale comprend des gradés
qui encore en réflexion parce que c'est
pas simple à monter mais souhaité qu'il
y ait le même parallèle entre le fonds
solidarité logement spécial kobe qui
avait été créée par les départements et
les bailleurs mais qui n'avait pas son
bureau dans les copropriétés dégradées
dont je rappelle que 84% des
copropriétés des copropriétés dégradées
en france sont situés à occuper v e
autre élément extrêmement important
l'augmentation du rsa plus de 20% à peu
près en moyenne dans nos collectivités
locales est pareil de la même manière
avec l'ensemble de mes collègues le même
phénomène
une augmentation de 30 à 40%
d'inscription auprès des associations
caritatives de deux types secours
populaire secours catholique et restos
du coeur pour l'aide alimentaire
la même manière très rapidement nos
communes ont dû faire face à la crise
alimentaire qui a été extrêmement forte
et soudaine et donc chacun et chacune
s'est su remobiliser des associations
caritatives
en certains endroits on est deux ou
trois en tête
allonnes sarthe à grigny mais aussi je
crois à chanteloup-les-vignes schéma
ma collègue catherine arenou les
associations caritatives se sont arrêtés
et donc ce sont les villes qui à partir
de leur épicerie sociale ont
complètement démultiplier leur leur aide
alimentaire
nous allons nous distribuer à grigny et
jusqu'à 1200 colis alimentaires par
semaine chose que nous n'avions qui
était vraiment inconnu
durant toute cette période nous étions
en lien extrêmement étroits et nous
avons pu auprès des ministères concernés
avoir quelques dispositifs particuliers
cartes et solidaire d'avoir des aides
financières pour les familles parce
qu'il y avait eu lieu à un fme last d'où
notre mobilisation après avoir travaillé
d'arrache-pied dans l'hyper proximité
sur la question des masques des crises
alimentaires cette interpellation
lorsque le train de la relance s'étaient
engagés voyons et c'est encore une fois
très très bien des plans territoriaux un
plan de relance pardon un plan de
relance territorialisée un coup la
ruralité un coup les dom tom et tant
mieux d'ailleurs je encore une fois je
crois que ces stratégies
mais nous n'avions pas de signaux sur
les quartiers populaires qui représente
quand même près de 6 millions
d'habitants
voilà donc cette cette période est
aujourd'hui ce que nous savons
d'expérience c'est que lorsqu'il ya une
crise et la dernière date de 2008 même
si elles étaient boursière elle a eu des
conséquences économiques et sociales
différé c'est que les crises dans les
quartiers populaires sont beaucoup plus
fortes impactante est beaucoup plus
durable que dans le reste du pays ou
dans une majorité des territoires
donc nous sommes aussi inquiet c'est la
raison de notre interpellation d'avoir
d'apporter des réponses à ces
populations qui pour certaines ne sont
pas protégés par le plan de relance et
entreprises
je parle encore une fois de cette armée
des précaires
les intérimaires et les fameux contrats
en cdd
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
ne nous sommes intervenus avec dans ce
débat là rappelez-vous le débat je
rentrerai pas dans le détail parce que
c'est pas le sujet du débat national qui
avait été engagé sur la question du
séparatisme du décrochage républicains
pour faire simple et un peu plus
consensuel et donc nous considérions que
la misère plus a mis l'accent sur
l'accélération de la misère de la
pauvreté de la précarité et est un
terreau aussi au décrochage république
et donc notre interpellation elle était
double évidemment sur le champ social
mais plus largement sur le champ
sociétal en disant attention s'il n'y a
pas des mesures adaptées forte puissante
les phénomènes de décrochage que nous
constatons risque de s'accentuer de
manière extrêmement forte
voilà ce que ce que nous avons le sens
de notre interpellation du du 14
novembre vous dire aujourd'hui que les
choses évidemment continue hausser un
peu relevé de ce premier confinement
mais que là encore la présence de
nouveaux arrivants dans nos centres
communaux d'action sociale dans les
associations caritatives continuent
d'affluer
nous avons des nouveaux des personnes
qui tapent à la porte
nous avons aussi pu découvrir et c'est
constater chez l'ensemble de mes
collègues situations notamment chez les
personnes âgées isolées qui alors certes
ne sont pas majoritaires puisque la
particularité de notre territoire c'est
que une sur représentation des
populations des enfants et de la
jeunesse
mais il ya aussi on l'oublié trop
souvent une part de personnes âgées
en fragilité aussi économiques et là
aussi ça a touché de plein fouet cette
population qui ait envie de dire est
souvent invisible parmi les invisibles
et donc là aussi en matière économique
mais surtout en matière de lien social
nous n'avons plus les uns et les autres
tisser les nouvelles pratiques
ça fait partie des choses elle est
positive de cette période extrêmement
difficile fait que nous avons adapté nos
services publics
nous avons tissé de nouvelles relations
avec les associations pour aller au plus
près des habitants et de celles et ceux
qu'ils étaient le plus isolés et en même
temps on va vers les plus isolés et en
même temps il ya de nouvelles personnes
qui viennent vers nous c'est le le
double mouvement que nous avons pu
constater peut-être un élément important
aussi parce que nous avons été fortement
mobilisés pendant le premier confinement
sur la crise éducative nos villes et
quartiers populaires concentre aussi
fléau celui de l'inégalité scolaire est
donc là aussi nous avons pu pour les
villes qui avaient des nouvelles
alliances éducatif notamment je pense à
celles et ceux qui est qu'ils étaient
engagés dans les cité éducative mais pas
que des pratiques nouvelles une forte
mobilisation des enseignants qui parfois
sont même devenus des relais pour
accompagner socialement des familles
je m'explique dans ce lien éducatif
il y a pu avoir des enseignants en lien
et on a fait ce en parfaite intelligence
avec l'éducation nationale qui ont pu
détecter leur les familles lorsqu'il ya
des ce lien avec les enfants des normes
fragilité alimentaires et donc
régulièrement il y avait des enseignants
et à l'éducation nationale a été
respectée un procès ce que nous avons
mis en place nous avons pu aller voir
des familles et répondre à des
problématiques alimentaires avec à
partir encore une fois de ce lien
éducatif et j'insiste beaucoup parce que
c'est bonne surprise de 2,2 cela deux de
ses amis enseigne éducatif qui dépasse
vous l'avez compris donc l'éducation
c'est le lien extrêmement nous avons
perdu très peu dans nos quartiers
populaires d'enfants selon laquelle
selon la description de l'éducation
nationale c'est à dire de l'absence de
lien de rupture totale de lien avec les
familles ou les enfants cette communauté
éducative au sens extrêmement large
associative fonctionnaires territoriaux
parents d'élèves et enseignants a permis
d'avoir très peu de perte de décrochage
éducatif et en même temps d'avoir un
lien social extrêmement étroits qui a
permis y compris de faire jouer des
solidarités de proximité voilà les
quelques éléments que je peux vous
apporter dans le quart d'heure et je
crois que
présentation frédérique massat merci
madame la présidente merci monsieur le
maire pour pour ses propos et de prendre
le temps de nous répondre mais au delà
je le dire merci pour cet appel parce
que je crois qu'effectivement les uns
les autres durant cette crise sanitaire
on a tous eu en tête ce qui peut se
passer dans des parts dans des
appartements très exigu avec sans doute
un confinement qui a été pour des
familles extrêmement compliqué et je
pense que c'était aussi un peu le sens
de votre de votre appel
en dehors de tout ce que vous nous avez
présenté alors vous l'avez vu un autre
notre notre mission vise à analyser
l'évolution de la précarisation et de la
paupérisation et un peu d'analysé des
mouvements de fragilisation ce que je
m'aperçois est ce qu'on s'aperçoit les
uns les autres c'est qu'au delà de ce
qu'on peut ressentir
il est très difficile d'objectiver les
choses est ce que au regard de ce que
vous vivez mais peut-être de ce qu'ont
vécu vos collègues qui ont lancé cet
appel
vous êtes en capacité de nous donner des
éléments chiffrés qu'ils soient sont
liées à des évolutions de public qui
peuvent fréquenter un certain nombre de
structures ou à ce basculement d'un
mouvement de précarisation un mouvement
de pauvreté moi j'ai bien entendu ce que
vous avez lancé sur ce que vous avez
appelé des précaires qui n'avaient pas
de filets je crois que c'est comme ça
que vous avez vous avez analysé des
choses alors c'est vrai que on peut être
favorable un certain nombre de choses
considérait qu'il y a eu pendant cette
crise des quartiers ou des secteurs qui
étaient un peu oublié mais force est de
constater quand même qu'un certain
nombre de dispositifs et de parachutes
sociaux ont été mises en place et quand
j'entends ce que vous me dites alors les
intérimaires par exemple ont été
couverts dans un deuxième temps un sur
sur les enjeux liés à notamment à
l'activité partielle
alors c'est vrai que ça a mis un peu de
temps à se mettre en place et c'est
peut-être l'écueil que vous avez pu
ressentir mais est-ce qu'au final quelle
est la population qui est effectivement
visée parce que vous énoncez c'est à
dire est ce que vous avez vraiment eu
des personnes qui n'avaient aucun filet
de protection et qui ont effectivement
basculer d'un système à l'autre donc ça
s'est un peu peut-être ma deuxième
question d'abord un an
activer les choses de cette cette partie
là et enfin comment est-ce que depuis
cet appel du 14 novembre
les choses ont un peu évolué et est ce
que vous êtes en mesure éventuellement
de de nous dire comment est ce qu'on
peut éventuellement développer des
solutions
si on devait avoir une crise de la sorte
ou un confinement de la sorte qu'ils ne
permettraient peut-être d'aller plus
vite et des vitres et d'éviter ce
basculement sur rio
d'abord sur l'appel j'insiste beaucoup
sur les 120 premières villes qui ont
signé cet appel
elles ne sont pas exclusivement des
villes caractérisée q pv quartier vous
politique de la ville dans les grandes
métropoles françaises
j'insiste beaucoup là dessus il y a eu
énormément de villes moyennes et ça a
été je ne vous cacherai pas une très
grande surprise de voir des villes
moyennes qui très rapidement se sont
joints à ce mouvement
c'est dans ces villes moyennes avec
cette nouvelle carte de dq pv et bien
dans chaque ville moyenne il y à un
quartier politique de la ville est en
fait je pense que nos collègues maires
voilà quand il ya un chiot dit viviane
en appelle au pardon madame artigalas
aux vaches ont beaucoup travaillé et
d'ailleurs je remercie le président du
sénat parce que de manière aussi
transpartisane nous avons été soutenus
par le sénat on a fait plusieurs
rencontres voilà albi aurillac cahors
montceau les mines le creusot des villes
de de ce type de villas ont rejoint le
mouvement extrêmement rapidement et ce
n'est qu'à la fin que les grandes villes
nantes paris nous ont rejoints cela
démontre que ça a frappé fortement
l'ensemble du pays en fait voilà je sais
ce que cette remarque me paraît
important vous avez raison les
intérimaires sont dans ma description
j'étais encore en mode premier
confinement là où il ya eu un effet
blast
en fait sur sur les conséquences et on a
senti très rapidement je suis élu depuis
bientôt dix ans sa mère depuis dix ans
et j'ai vécu toute ma vie dans cette
ville qui je le rappelle
triste record d'avoir le taux de
pauvreté de environ 50 % de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
et donc d'avoir été classé par
l'observatoire des inégalités comme la
ville la plus pauvre
on va encore dans notre cabine de
pilotage on pilote un peu
malheureusement un peu dans le
brouillard parfois parce que comme vous
nous sommes dans la tente d'objectiver
de manière beaucoup plus scientifique
les éléments le suivi régulier des ré ça
c'est le département la question de
l'emploi et pôle emploi
et on peut faire la démarche comme ça et
nous très rapidement les éléments que
l'on peut vous dire c'est le nombre
d'inscrits en plus au centre communal
d'action sociale mais qui peuvent elles
pour diverses raisons
ça peut être avec nos partenaires
associatifs les plus 30 à 40% ça on les
a régulièrement avec nos associations ou
l'aide sociale d'augmenter
on avait un autre critère aussi dans
cette interpellation est des plus hauts
scores au décrochage mais bon ça c'est
un sujet extrêmement important mais
annexes par rapport à votre à vos
interrogations du moment donc il manque
véritablement quelque chose pour bien
piloter ce qui sera encore long et donc
on espère beaucoup de cette période
permet d'être beaucoup plus agile dans
cette observation dans l'objectivation
alors pour autant nous avons eu à grigny
une démarche singulière c'est que nous
ne sommes pas contentés de cette
interpellation du 14 novembre et en
clair d'interpeller les crédits
politique de la ville qui je le rappelle
est quelques-uns j'utilisais beaucoup
représente moins d'un pour cent du
budget de l'état et même si la politique
de la ville est une politique à 360
degrés c'est à dire qu'on fait de la
santé ont fait du logement ont fait de
l'emploi on fait plein de choses fait
plus haut à l'onf et la culture on fait
du sport ce qui nous paraissait
important c'était de territorialiser la
stratégie nationale de prévention et de
lutte contre la pauvreté
dit autrement dans notre jargon
mobiliseront d'abord les outils de droit
commun puissant et massif
laissons la politique de la ville être
ce qu'elle sait faire de la
transversalité de la politique
territoriale
mais faisons en sorte que lier une
application massive pour faire face à
cette accélération de pauvreté et misère
nous avons donc tendu la main lors du la
venue de madame la ministre nadia et le
18 décembre dernier qui a qui étaient
passés juste avant à roubaix et ensuite
chanté chance pour les vignes et à qui a
terminé sa fin janvier 2001 à grigny en
présence de madame jean tequila ses
pulsions délégué interministériel au
commissaire général je ne sais plus est
la lutte contre la pauvreté et nous
avons bien évidemment abordé la question
politique de la ville mais surtout
stratégie nationale de prévention et de
lutte contre la pauvreté
nous avons donc remis vingt-et-une
solution c'était pour l'année 2000 21
n'aurait été en 2025 nous aurions trouvé
2025 date est une solution à partir
d'éléments un peu objectif mais qui
étaient les éléments d'al en crise
on se rappelle que l'observatoire des
inégalités qui vont faire pauvreté
s'appuie sur les chiffres de 2010 est
et donc bon force est de constater
qu'aujourd'hui
voilà c'est pas que les chiffres sont
dépassées mais se sont pas améliorées ça
c'est certain
et donc nous avons à partir de nos
projets locaux coller à la stratégie de
prévention et de lutte contre la
pauvreté à travers 21 une proposition
qui vont de j'étais ce matin avec
messieurs les ministres et madame la
secrétaire d'état sur les petits
déjeuners la tarification sociale dans
les antilles donc nous étions par
exemple sur la généralisation des lois
de bessan la généralisation des petits
déjeuners dans les maternelles qui est
un sujet nous étions également sur les
places de crèche
parce que dans nos territoires il y a
moins de places de crèches que dans la
moyenne nationale
nous étions bien évidemment sur les
premiers éléments du plan de relance je
pense pour la jeunesse la garantie
jeunes et son doublement chose qui a été
bien évidemment actée et nous avons
comme ça définit un certain nombre
d'actions extrêmement concrètes
applicables et nous sommes dans une
phase d'expérimentation à l'échelle
locale donc mobilisation de tous les
acteurs type caisse d'allocations
familiales cpm ars tous les outils
partenariat social à la mode française
bien évidemment les services de l'état
la ville le département on essaye
d'embarquer évidemment le département
dans cette aventure et avec un pilotage
relativement fort entre la préfecture et
là la délégation régionale 2 du plan
doute contre la pauvreté donc voilà ce
qui nous paraissait nous important pour
faire face
allez on l'appelle aussi le tsunami des
réponses appropriées
bien évidemment sont à chercher dans le
plan de relance sans à chercher dans le
comité interministériel à la ville qui
s'est tenue le 29 mai besoin aussi de
le challenge est d'interroger l'ensemble
de cette politique publique qui n'était
pas trop tomber à une échelle locale
nous on a fait cette proposition on
s'est doté de cet outil là et on
travaille de la même manière dans ce
plan prendrait un autre exemple les
questions de santé
c'est pas une réponse pour limiter de la
situation mais sur le déserts médicaux
dont nous sortons petit à petit par
exemple nous demandons le financement
d'une échographie de pour les
gynécologues
nous avons des gynécologues des médecins
gynécologues qui veulent venir mais pour
la ville qui en essonne en tout cas dans
un département jeunes un taux de
natalité extrêmement important la
question du suivi extrêmement important
et donc nous avons ciblé dans ce dans
ses vertes et une solution les
radiographies pour gynécologue voilà
pour qu' on puisse avoir accès à ce soin
dans la proximité voilà une grande
palette et je terminerai je terminerais
une dernière chose qui nous paraît
extrêmement important c'est la question
de l'accès aux droits
c'est là où je pense que notre système
doivent beaucoup évolué en train curatif
tellement individualisé qui devient trop
compliqué et du préventif
je dis cela parce que depuis un an et
demi deux ans avec la caisse
d'allocations familiales nous avons fait
un diagnostic territorial avec à travers
une cpge et convention territoriale
globale et nous nous sommes aperçus des
non recours au droit qui excusez moi
l'expression est quasiment un sport
national en fait dans les quartiers
populaires parce que électro l'isthme
parce qu'on parce que complexification
des démarches parce que hyper
individualisation tout s'accumule et
fait qu'on a des sports décrochage je
voudrais deux chiffres que je donne très
régulièrement pour les personnes âgées à
peu près 20 à 30 % des gens vivent
seules et 2010 minimum vieillesse
et sur les familles monoparentales qui
sont très présentes dans nos quartiers
populaires c'est plus de 30% et
craignez-vous près de 30% en chiffres en
valeur absolue ses 1600 et il n'y en a
que six ans qu'ils perçoivent
l'un pays c'est à dire l'aide
personnalisée à l personnel
individualisé pardon et donc on voit
bien que sur un certain nombre de sujets
cette période doit nous réinterroger sur
nos pratiques et les méthodes utilisées
pour toucher les publics fragiles
vulnérables voire précaire mais on
manque encore d'objectivation des choses
ces notes c'est notre souci
voilà j'ai bien regardé par
ok si vous avez posées aux réponses ce
que des sénateurs et sénatrices présent
au reste des questions ils viennent art
il agace merci merci madame la
présidente madame la rapporteure
monsieur le maire oui moi je
effectivement vous en ces débuts au
sénat lors de votre venue parce que
l'équipement le scénariste est quand
même très très sensibilisés à votre
appel
moi j'avais retourne de chose j'aimerais
avoir parce que bon depuis il ya eu
aussi des mesures qui ont été prises par
le gouvernement dans le cadre du
programme de relance et moi mon
inquiétude et qui est la vôtre citer que
ces mesures n'arrivait toujours pas sur
les quartiers politique de la ville et
donc j'ai deux questions on avait vu
ensemble que pendant que les appels à
projets pour les associations qui
avaient déjà un moment donné et elle
était tellement prise par le travail de
terrain qu'elle avait à faire et pire ou
que c'était suite au confinement dans le
travail qu'ils avaient à faire parce
qu'effectivement il ya énormément de
demandes des habitants des quartiers
politique de la ville qu'elle n'avait
pas eu le temps de répondre à ses appels
à projets et que tous ces gens seulement
qui finalement leur est venue
prioritairement destinée était peut être
allée à d'autres associations qui
étaient moins prêts du terrain donc
savoir où ça en élite et si jamais ya
même des ados qui étaient là et la
deuxième chose mais effectivement nous
avions demandé dans le cadre du budget
politique de la ville et y ait beaucoup
plus de cité éducative qui soient
déployés de ployer vous avez bien me
montrer lequel vous aviez parlé de
l'intérêt qu'elle avait même s'il
n'avait pas été évalué contenant leurs
actions avaient été très très importante
avance confinement mener aussi après
pour maintenir une forme 2 il exultait
d'égalité républicaine et sur la
question de l'école et de la continuité
pédagogique et je voulais
il a été prévu dans le cadre du plan de
relance peu des sites éducative non
moins important que ce que nous aurions
souhaité pas mis en place est ce que
c'est comment iv est ce que ces mesures
sont là et ensuite je voulais je voulais
vous dire aussi je voulais répondre un
petit peu aussi par rapport des partis
politiques de la ville il y en a
beaucoup à redire aussi stéphane ne me
contredira et nous entrons dans les
jours tu m'as fait un travail justement
avec stéphane artano et nassimah dindar
sur le champ économique a new comer
suite au kobus visage et c'est vrai que
c'est une grosse partie de l'économie
mais je autres herbes et ça doit être
dans certains quartiers basé sur des
associations sur une de l'économie
informelle et qui s'étend sur coup d'un
arrêté et on a vu aussi un travail que
faisait lundi
et est-ce qu'il intervient l'adie
l'association à l'enjeu n'est pas
nouveau jeu du mal avec les cycles est
ce qu elle intervient aussi cette
association en les quartiers politique
de la ville voilà mes questions stéphane
et tu pourrais leur dire ce que c'est la
dyle exactement jouent ce même plus
attention par l'économique non oui voilà
l'insertion par l'économique voilà
association des de l'insertion par
l'économique voilà merci bien répondre
le sens de la mobile de l'interpellation
du 14 novembre reposait sur deux piliers
bien évidemment la question des moyens
qui était le 1 % du plan de relance
correspondant à un milliard la réponse
était de 2 milliards en rue et un
milliard trois plans de relance faire
simple un fléchage particulier et vos
c'était la question de la méthode où
nous nous étions posé la question de
cheveux technique du ruissellement que
l'on connaît touche qui entre
l'annoncent et la mise en pratique sur
le territoire est extrêmement complet et
donc nous avions porté l'idée d'un
conseil national des solutions qui
permettait de dire mais les territoires
on des solutions parfois même avéré
solide qui peuvent être support de
d'expérimentation nationale c'est à dire
d'aller dans l'autre sens ce que les
anglais appellent le tom darnal bottom
up et biner d'études sont très féru de
ce terme là donc on fait remonter les
solutions est typiquement nous nous
appuyons très fortement sur la question
p cité éducative
nous avions tous en germe ce qui
aujourd'hui est cité une khatib
il se trouve que gagne a été peut-être
détonateur même certainement dans le
cadre du but du rapport borloo et de
l'après borloo et c'est bien d'abord et
avant tout une pratique locale qui est
devenue nationale
et là effectivement quatre premières
séries 80 cité éducative 40 de ce que
nous avons obtenu c'est que les deux
sens cité éducative à la fin du
quinquennat
c'est ça à l'engagement du du premier
ministre lors de sa venue à grigny le 29
janvier dernier
donc j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus parce
que sur la méthode descendante
fondamentalement je pense qu'il ya
indigestion
parce que quand on regarde entre les
plans de relance les déclinaisons des
plans de relance le ségur de la santé le
comité interministériel à la ville
c'est pas simple voilà de s'y retrouver
on est face à un vrai rubicube
excusez-moi l'expression mais je la
jeune utilise souvent et tout ça dans
une organisation et c'est pas une
critique mais juste un constat
dans une organisation où ça passe par
les préfectures et qui sont hyper
concentré sur la question de la
vaccination est donc objectivement la
descente est compliqué j'ai assisté avec
d'autres collègues nous sommes assistés
dans la vie dans le pour la mise en
application du comité interministériel à
la ville par le conseil national des
villes
cette instance avec des élus des
associations des personnes qualifiées
les professionnels pour faire simple on
l'a fait avant le cjb parce que nous
étions porteur de solutions 14 et donc
là nous travaillons nous insistions nous
insistons énormément sur rendre les
choses aller je reprends le mot à la
mode agile
aujourd'hui c'est le très compliqué et à
la question de madame la sénatrice
artigalas sur les associations
aujourd'hui il ya autant de mesures que
d'appels à projets et même pour les
villes alors celles qui ont peu de
moyens et peu d'ingénérie c'est même pas
la peine selon on n'y arrivera jamais
pour les associations c'est pareil la
crainte est toujours là même si pendant
la période on a simplifié un certain
nombre de choses
je tiens à dire parce que dans la
période de crise aiguë premier semestre
nous avons pu aller extrêmement vite sur
quartier des quartiers d'été vacances un
prenantes qui se sont déclenchés au mois
de mars au mois d'avril
il attire l'attention assure s'inquiéter
pour nous aussi une bonne réussite
d'entente de co construction d'une
politique adaptée à la situation réelle
et le gouvernement a fait preuve de
réactivité sur vacances un prenantes et
quartier n'était voire même ce qu'on
appelle quartier solidaire puisqu'on a
eu un certain nombre
financière au plus de chèque de chaque
service au plus dur de la crise donc on
a su on a su s'adapter mais là j'avoue
que sur les craintes associations y a
pas un jour sans un appel à projets quoi
et donc objectivement ça reste très
compliquée à mettre en oeuvre et on
travaille encore je encore cette semaine
on a des rencontres
l'ensemble des collègues sur
l'atterrissage des mesures sur le
territoire d'autant que certaines sont
voit être très compliqué objectivement à
mettre en oeuvre
au-delà de cette indigestion et de cette
méthode c'est par exemple tout ce qui
relève des contrats aidés
je prendrai juste l'exemple de la
garantie jeunes débutent quinquennat il
ya eu un stop qui a d'ailleurs donné la
peine de grigny en octobre 2017 sur les
contrats aidés
et puis là il ya 1 go c'est à dire qu'on
va retrouver peuvent ou prou les niveaux
de début de quinquennat et donc le stop
and go il et il est extrêmement
compliqué et doublé en six mois le
nombre de garanties jeunes c'est mais
c'est la qualité de l'accompagnement
tout simplement je dis ça en tant que a
directement responsable de mission
locale mais je les ai été et on est tous
très près de nos missions locales qui
font le travail pour ces garanties donc
atterrissage compliqué il ya un port
bouchons à une forte indigestion un
appareil d'état qui est concentré sur
autre chose objectivement la perte de
quantité d'agents dans les préfectures
aux questions voilà je sais quelque
chose que l'on a tous
alors bien évidemment il ya du
volontarisme donne au préfet à l'égalité
des chances et personne ne remet en
cause la mets en cause ceux là pardon
mais il manque quand même du monde pour
pour pour cette période
et puis à quelques sujets qui nous
paraissent compliqués d'applications
type typiquement garantie jeunes en six
mois doublé nombre de 46 jeunes
ça l'a relevé d'exploit ou d'une qualité
de suivi -
ce qu il yad autres
personne c'est un personnage qui peuvent
intervenir moi j'ai peut-être une fusion
a demandé un peu dans la continuité de
ce que vous venez de dire et de ce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure vous avez
inventé de nouvelles pratiques est ce
que ces nouvelles pratiques peuvent être
je dirais un peu théorisé si je peux le
dire comme ça pour être développés est
démultipliée sur éventuellement d'autres
territoires où nous avons tous véhicules
pendant cette période avec les collègues
nous étions en lien extrêmement étroits
en fait et on s'est aperçu que on avait
les mêmes phénomènes
je prends par exemple tout à l'heure
j'ai parlé des personnes âgées souvent
isolées
pas toujours mais isolé nous avons
obligation dans nos communes d'avoir des
plans canicule et donc de répertorier un
certain nombre de personnes dites
fragiles pour anticiper les périodes de
canicule et avoir des contacts réguliers
pendant ces périodes là ce soit le maire
d'evry courcouronnes président de
l'association des maires d'ile-de-france
où mes collègues de villes et banlieues
on a multiplié par 2 3 4 5
parfois notre base de données
personnes fragiles plan canicule et
personnes qu vide c'est la même
catégorie d'âge et donc ça dans les
changements de pratiques
c'est à dire qu'on a été beaucoup plus
loin dans la prise de contact parce que
l'urgence nécessité d'aller beaucoup
plus loin et ça ça comme conséquence
alors faudrait le mesurer auprès
d'autres collègues mais je pense qu'ils
l'ont autrefois nous nous étions à 40
livraison de repas à domicile par le
service municipal
par jour aujourd'hui nous sommes à 140
et donc on voit bien que ça interroge
beaucoup nos pratiques municipales
ça a bouleversé notre service public
il ya un peu plus de polyvalence aussi
haut on est aussi sorti de nos
politiques de silos le dit un jeu on
critique souvent l'état mais nous aussi
nos collectivités on a on a bougé et il
ya des nouveaux métiers qui se feront
notre plateforme alimentaire qui dit se
trouver jusqu'à 1200 repas il a été fait
par un ensemble de fonctionnaires qui
n'étaient pas dans l'action sociale et
pas dans la restauration mais qui a fait
l'objet d'une mobilisation de tous et ça
voilà je veux dire positivement impacté
aussi le sens du service public y
compris à l'échelle territoriale et dans
nos et dans nos villes également
donc ça c'est un bien précieux important
mais on ne mesure pas encore toutes les
les évolutions termes d'organisation
mais ça bouge beaucoup dans nos communes
ça c'est évident ça nous a percutés gens
me dire positivement parce que on a
réussi des choses voilà je vous donne
très concrètement de 40 à 140 sur les
repas à domicile x 3 quand même ce qui
nous a fait aussi vous interroger sur la
politique tarifaire
alors on a pris et unique on a arrêté le
quotient pour se casser la tête
on en a on a simplifié facile du coup
notre plan canicule pour l'été mais on a
dans notre base de données
x 4 ou 5 des risques et les personnes
identifiées potentiellement merci même
le rapport tard oui oui peut-être deux
dernières questions une question on a un
dada en commission sociale on considère
qu' un certain nombre d'emplois aidés
qui sont pas forcément très utilisé et
quand je vous entends parler monsieur le
maire je me dis que vous n'avez jamais
citer le terme d'emploi francs donc vous
allez dans le sens de la commission
sociale parce que ce sont quand même des
emplois qui sont adaptés à votre votre
contexte vous ai parlé de garantie
jeunes mais ils emploient front n'ont
pas été cités voilà est-ce que c'est une
solution qui peut être
même si vous nous sommes assez sceptique
mais j'aimerais vous entendre sur le
sujet et puis la deuxième chose sur les
perspectives et des solutions et une
petite question un peu provocatrice mais
du coup je vais utiliser un
intermédiaire qui est l'institut
montaigne un qui était une question qui
vous est posée sur effectivement le
rapport qui a été fait qui s'intitule
s'intituler quartiers pauvres ont un
avenir
est-ce que la solution n'est peut-être
pas dans des enjeux je pense notamment
aux bascules là je reviens sur mes
enfants de bascule de précarisation à
pauvreté sur des enjeux d'aménagement du
territoire et est ce que là la question
de l'institut bouteille un peu
provocatrice j'en conviens consistant à
dire qu'il faut que dans les quartiers
politique de la ville on limite le
pourcentage de logements sociaux est une
piste qui peuvent éventuellement
améliorer l'aménagement du territoire et
peut-être une prise en charge est plus
individualisé que dans des grandes
villes aussi un peu plus compliqué et
bien alors
mais merci de cette question je suis de
ceux qui pensent que l'aménagement du
territoire est un à penser de notre
société pour le moins chez moi tu propos
provocateurs mais vous allez me
comprendre la concurrence libre et non
faussée s'est impliqué à l'aménagement
du territoire qui par nature est
interventionniste et nous sommes rentrés
depuis une vingtaine d'années dans une
concurrence des territoires
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous nous
sommes extrêmement vigilants à dire les
territoires vulnérables c'est pas que
les quartiers populaires c'est les dom
tom c'est les territoires ruraux isolés
ce sont les bassins de reconversion
parce que si on s'oppose entre
territoires fragiles c'est c'est
mortifère
donc on fait extrêmement attention et
effectivement il faut repenser
l'aménagement du territoire cela vaut
aussi
j'assiste beaucoup sur les mines moyenne
1 c'est aussi la crise béziers les
jaunes etc
kir et interrogent notre modèle est donc
sur la question de l'institut montel que
j'avais bien en tête et sur lesquels on
combat
apporter des réponses il faudrait qu'il
n'ait plus d'avenir pour la pauvreté
plutôt que
des quartiers pauvres ont un avenir
parce que dans les phénomènes de
métropolisation le grignotage de la
gentrification fait qu' il ya des
quartiers des territoires qui seront de
moins en moins peau mais avec des
phénomènes de comment dire en plus je
devrais le trouver les pauvres ont
habité en deuxième couronne troisième
couronne comme on peut le voir
actuellement en fait dans les métropoles
et donc ce phénomène là étaient
extrêmement inquiétants
on le voit nous dans nos territoires
grigny et en seconde couronne de la
région parisienne est un véritable sujet
sur la question que vous posez sur la
construction de logements sociaux
je dis attention et je vais être un peu
provocateur ses tartes à la crème
parce que le vrai sujet c'est la
question de l'attribution
nos territoires sont le réceptacle des
politique d'attribution et là où on se
focalise où le débat public et locale
est focalisée sur la construction de
logements qui est un débat mais en fait
ça représente que relativement peu par
rapport par rapport au nombre
d'attributions aux interrogations que
l'on doit avoir sur quel bilan des
dalots sur quel stress quel bilan des
stratégies des préfectures dans leur
public en difficulté qui sont
principalement orientés dans les
territoires qui ont un parc hlm très
social très social parce que construit
depuis très longtemps ou l'aide à la
pierre est extrêmement présente et c'est
avec ces cas là nous avons fait nous
d'ailleurs des propositions à madame la
ministre puisque le sujet s est rué
construite en logements sociaux donc oui
sur les histoires de 40% et cetera mais
on est sur du temps long quand on parle
de construction de logements sociaux une
attribution de logement social toutes
les semaines on attribue des milliers et
des milliers de logements sociaux
toutes les semaines on construit pas des
milliers et des milliers de logements
donc oui au rééquilibrage
oui à la loi sru mais attention
le vrai sujet il est d'abord et avant
tout dans les attributions et dans les
politiques d'attribution de logements
sociaux est les territoires qui sont des
territoires nas pour ça sur une
particularité d'avoir du logement fait
très social et mr automatiquement quand
on a des publics en difficulté on les
met dedans et c'est sans fin grigny pour
ça est un exemple terrible entre une
copropriété qui attire dégradé et un
quartier de type hlm avec un kid qui est
classifié logement très social à moins
de 5 euros le mètre carré hors charges
et bien effectivement le préfet je ne
comprends quand il n'a pas de solution
ben il vient dans un parc hlm de ce type
là et puis comme il a un droit de
réservation important est qu'il ya 3500
logements
il a un stock de logements
mais tout ça a des conséquences sur
l'éducatif tout ça a des conséquences
sur sur la reproduction etc etc
et donc voilà je pense très clairement
que le peu vrai sujet et sur sur
l'attribution de deux logements et il
nous faut une véritable révolution dans
notre pays sur cette question là on
propose d'ailleurs sur les solutions
c'était un peu dur mais que les villes
qui ne respectent pas la loi sru bas
c'est eux qui prennent les publics les
plus en difficulté
parce que chez eux d'abord les publics
en difficulté seront dans un contexte
beaucoup plus facile pour s'en sortir
l'accompagnement sera plus facile mais
si on met des pauvres chez les pauvres
ça va être très difficile de s'en sortir
et voilà genre de noeux un peu
mathématiques
mon explication mais genre de solution
qui nous paraissent importantes et de
limiter bien évidemment la question du
déplafonnement des loyers on vient de
sortir une situation à gré 10 ou à
monsieur a nommé seule avec deux enfants
il peut pas accéder au logement très
social alors qu'il a envie d'être là
parce qu'il a des liens familiaux parce
qu'il dit a grandi veut revenir et en
fait on lui dit il est trop riche et
donc on a plein de petit curseur comme
ça à travailler mais je me pense
véritablement que c'est le sujet de
notre pays et excusez moi c'est pas
tarte à la crème 1 le sujet de la
construction mais vraiment secondaire
je crois que j'ai répondu à vos
questions c'est papa des copropriétés
100 francs peut-être oui sur les
contrats aidés c'est le stop and go
comme ça a été stoppée et ça
fonctionnait pas voilà pour certains
là on nous demande d'utiliser plein de
contrats aidés
il ya des entreprises qui pourront pas
donc on peut alors proposer nous les
collectivités locales on est un peu en
difficulté
c'est pas simple donc on attend de voir
mais c'est compliqué voilà le
financement à 80% des peco plus pvc très
bien bon ça faisait quatre cinq ans
qu'on le demande et on aurait pu aller
plus vite quand même en fait son
démantèlement des prises de position
idéologique qui est aujourd'hui une
pause les difficultés voilà donc sur les
contrats signés ben en fait maintenant
on est on est un peu dans la seringue
excusez moi l'expression
il faut toujours utiliser et extrêmement
vite et ça c'est extrêmement compliqué
par et sur les comprend pardon vous n'y
avez une question sur les copropriétés
qu'on m'a posée à l'oral mais j'apporte
quelques éléments donc observatoire des
impayés de charges ça c'est acté pense
véritablement que dans notre pays on
doit créer un fonds de solidarité pour
comprendre dégradé qui n'existe pas
d'invidu alizé est trop difficile dans
le collectif on sait pas si la facture
est les impayés parce que c'est un
problème d'eau c'est un problème de
chauffage c'est un problème
d'électricité c'est un problème de je ne
sais quoi
et donc on a inventé un système il faut
mutualiser les choses on a fait des
propositions pour que la hongroise
mutation une petite proportion soit
permettent d'avoir un fonds spécial
d'intervention sur les coteaux on a
identifié 14 dans ce pays qui sont en
très grande difficulté je pense
notamment que notre pays a intérêt même
s'il est devenu mature sur les
copropriétés dégradées doit accélérer
sur les syndicats de redressement public
c'est à dire qu'on se donne les moyens
de gérer est véritablement la crise va
fragiliser les copropriétés ce système
où les pacte de solidarité entre
propriétaires bombes ont explosé avec la
crise
pour être dans une ville de 5000
copropriété en très grande difficulté ce
cheveu mesures tous les jours cela et
j'alerte fortement on a besoin de deux
garde-fous en matière de gestion en
matière de syndic ceux des efforts que
notre pays a fait sur des labels de
qualité indique à de redressement dans
les copropriétés fragile je considère
qu'il est un échec parce que les
phénomènes de dégradation et
d'incompréhension se poursuivre et là on
a un vrai sujet dans les mois et les
dans les semaines les mois et les années
à venir et qu'on propriété fragiles vont
devenir encore plus fragiles le bailleur
social est un amortisseur et on a besoin
donc d'un baromètre d'un thermomètre
c'est l'observatoire qui est en cours de
travail avec l'anah et les ministères du
logement
mais très rapidement la question d'un
fonds de soutien ou d'un fonds de
solidarité pour continuer à assurer
l'eau et le chauffage est vraiment jeu
il ya des phénomènes et d'autres
collègues que j'ai alerté parce que on
avait constaté ça à grigny constate
qu'il ya effectivement des impayés en
matière d'eau et de chauffage
une question de madame chaînage et donc
madame la sénatrice je vous laisse la
parole oui je voudrais revenir sur la
loi est restée rue bonjour vous avez
parlé aussi de la première couronne
autour de deux grandes îles de la
paupérisation la pauvreté mais il ya
aussi un peu plus loin la ruralité est
ce que vous sentez aussi ou peut-être
les gens qui vivent dans la ruralité au
moins la proximité revenir en ville
quand ils se sont face à une grande
pauvreté ou plutôt aller de rester dans
la ruralité est consternant moi je le
vois dans mon département et je j'ai
intervient beaucoup en ce moment il ya
des villes qui ont vraiment envie
d'aller dans la construction de faire
les benchs 1%
ils n'ont parfois pas les terrains pas
les moyens et l'autre chose on pousse de
nombreuses villes à augmenter leurs
habitations sociales sauf que quand on
augmente de 25%
il faut augmenter des écoles et
périscolaire tous les services mhcs et
comment vous dans votre ville vous
ressentez ça est ce que vous allez les
moyens comme en voilà et la situation
alors d'abord je vais aller contre une
idée préconçue le logement social est
une solution même dans les quartiers
populaires je redis le logement social
est une solution dans les quartiers
populaires notamment logement social
adapté pour les jeunes publics pour les
publics les plus anciens pour les
familles monoparentales c'est les
solutions de même que lorsqu'on a un
parc social très social on arrive à
faire aussi du parc social - sociale
excusez moi je entre les pma i pour
faire simple et les plus c'est pas le
même niveau de ressources et donc là on
voit bien qu'il ya des paliers qu'il ne
faut pas écarter par principe
idéologique
nous ne voyons pas de retour
deux personnes issues de territoires
ruraux en territoire urbain moi je ne
constate pas j'avais constaté des
italiens et des espagnols qui
remontaient dans notre territoire
ceux de dix issus de deux migrations
plus lointaine que l'italie et l'espagne
ça nous l'avons constaté il ya trois
quatre ans en clair quand il est crise
en espagne en italie c'est remonter mais
pas depuis la crise qu vite des
phénomènes nouveaux
par contre les habitants on a nous je le
dis je suis en deuxième couronne on a
des agents communaux qui s'est pas tarie
anodin ont décidé d'habiter dans la
ruralité pour chez nous dans l'yonne où
dans le loiret ce sont aussi les
travailleurs qui souffrent de du trajet
domicile travail et j'ai envie de dire
des filets jaunes en puissance aussi le
dit de cette manière là donc on a des
travailleurs qui sont comme ça dans nos
dans nos villes et ça vaut dans le nord
de paris où ils vont dans l'oise ou des
choses comme ça donc on a ce type de
phénomène ensuite sur sur les effets du
logement social
effectivement si on a un parc de
logement social qui est composé comme à
grigny à plus de 60% de p4 et p5
on a beaucoup d'enfants ce qui fait
beaucoup d'impact dans les écoles ce qui
fait beaucoup d'impact sur la
restauration ce qui fait beaucoup
d'impact sur le périscolaire
ce qui fait que nous nous minutes ont
par exemple avec villes et banlieues à
l'instauration d'une dotation pour
surcharge colère parce qu'il ya des
territoires qui par la structure de
l'habitat attire des familles nombreuses
et objectivement ça c objective et fait
que nous avons pour une même population
moi je prends de ville à côté de moi
30000 habitants pareil j'ai mille cinq
cents enfants de plus à scolariser
parents 1500 enfants à scolariser ces
jeux par le groupe scolaire là et donc
ce sont des dépenses obligatoires
et quant à cette jeunesse on y met de la
pauvreté ben on parle pas on part pas au
même on n'est pas tous sur la même ligne
de débats en fait donc le logement
social il peut être calibrée pour du t3
pour du t4 il peut être qualifiée pour
les populations fragiles et qui peuvent
être des familles monoparentales et donc
la question de la croche du logement
social aussi par la typologie est aussi
un élément important qui cassent démis
parce que notamment dans les secteurs un
peu tendu les enfants qui veulent
décohabiter ils ne peuvent pas d'écho
habiter dans le logement a privé ce
n'est pas vrai financièrement ils ne
peuvent pas et donc le logement social
que est une solution pour céder
cohabitation de jeunes pour ces
fractures de la vie si je parle de
divorce ça existe dans notre pays ce qui
fait que ces familles recomposées
doivent se recomposer et trouvait dans
le logement de la sécurité et non pas de
la précarité
donc le logement social
ça offre tous est tout ce panel là deux
possibilités
donc je vous avez compris je suis pas là
pour diaboliser le logement social
loin de là mais si on creuse un peu ce
sont des solutions adaptées voilà
l'expérience de quelqu'un qui est un peu
d'expérience beaucoup je crois que l'art
est passé également que nous allons être
devoir nous quitter nous allons
poursuivre nos travaux de notre côté
mais je voudrais vraiment remercier en
fait pour votre présence avec nous cet
après midi et demain à porter peut-être
si vous avez dans l'autre merci
également si on remarque et nous
attendons aussi vos contributions
et si c'est possible donc très bien
merci beaucoup de votre attention et vos
questions très pertinentes
merci beaucoup bonne continuation
[Musique]